the eyeballs in this country are are on
instagram
and at tick tock right you you
essentially have kind of an older
demographic
that are on facebook that are probably
over the age of 50
from 50 down to 25 instagram just
dominates the market and then under 25
is which which is really scary this is
scary as hell uh chinese owned tick tock
and all these young people on tick tock
so
for us to
and for us to compete with with twitter
like like that's you know look you know
we're not gonna ban people that's kind
of an easy market for us like people
that want to be on twitter get news that
sort of thing because your twitter sucks
so bad and a lot of a lot of our people
are never going to go back go back to
twitter so that's an that's kind of an
easy market but to really grow this
company we've got to get into the
mainstream of of people that are don't
want to just do politics and news all
the time but want to communicate and
actually
social network
uh you know knowing that we're not going
to shove some algorithm in their face i
think that's our comparative advantage
is we're going to do
every we're going to do a lot of things
really well
but you're not going to be canceled
we're not going to steal your data we're
not going to shove some algorithm into
your phone on the stuff that we think
you need to see
it's so interesting because the the
problems that you are trying to solve
for yourself are exactly what led you to
this new career and that's exactly why i
started locals i was having the same
exact problems as you as you'll love
this one i remember this is a couple
years ago now when i was about to hit a
million subscribers on youtube and at
the time you may remember you could go
on socialblade where they did a live
track of subscribers so you could
literally just watch a graph and the
numbers would grow and i would every
time i got within about 20 000 of a
million i would lose 50 000 and then it
would slowly grow again and then i'd
lose 40 000 and it took me months when i
when it should have been way before and
then what did socialblade do well
youtube deactivated their api so they
could no longer track in real time
because it was becoming too obvious so
one of the things that i say all the
time about social media
it's not the stuff that we know that
they're doing i'm worried about it's the
stuff that we do not know that i'm most
worried about so okay so all of that
added up uh how is truth going to solve
some of the problems we could go into
all of the shadow banning you don't see
subscriber videos uh you know the bands
the censorship okay fine we can do all
that my audience gets it how is truth
gonna solve some of this stuff yeah so
so look i mean one of the one of the
things that we're doing is we're riding
on top of we call it riding on rumble
the rumble rails right so the same thing
that locals is using you know rumble is
getting into that marketplace it's
critically important because you know we
have to have data centers that these big
giant tech companies can't can't kill
and cut off right
so that's why you know we've partnered
we've partnered with rumble and then
what we're doing like the product we're
trying to that we're that we're building
out right now
uh is is one that that we envision
is taking kind of the best of all these
social media companies that are out
there
um in terms of you know twitter is kind
of just a simple message board um then
you have a lot better technology at
instagram facebook and and tick tock so
we're trying to take the best of best of
all of that and put it into into one
platform and people who have who i've
seen you know who have seen true social
uh you know which were only you know
just a few months old right now
and we're right now we just have a
simple chronological feed uh no we don't
use any algorithms but you will see
already that we are trying to
do a really good job with video and
no surprise we're using rumble for our
video infrastructure so we're trying to
tie
all of this together so that we have a
product that takes the best of all these
social media companies because
then i said that we would come back to
this
and here we are
the you know the eyeballs in this
country are on instagram
and at tick tock right you essentially
have kind of an older demographic
that are on facebook that are probably
over the age of 50
from 50 down to 25 instagram just
dominates the market and then under 25
is which which this is really scary this
is scary as hell uh chinese owned tick
tock and all these young people on tick
tock so
for us to
i mean for us to compete with with
twitter like like that's you know look
you know we're not going to ban people
that's kind of an easy market for us
like people that want to be on twitter
get news that sort of thing because you
know twitter sucks so bad and a lot of a
lot of our people are never going to go
back go back to twitter so that's that's
kind of an easy market but to really
grow this company we've got to get into
the mainstream of of people that are
don't want to just do politics and news
all the time but want to communicate and
actually
social network
uh you know knowing that we're not going
to shove some algorithm in their face i
think that's our comparative advantage
is we're going to do
every we're going to do a lot of things
really well
but you're not going to be canceled
we're not going to steal your data we're
not going to shove some algorithm into
your phone on the stuff that we think
you need to see and that's our
comparative advantage and it's really
just about filling out the feature set
so
you know we're in the apple app store
we've been there for a couple months now
we just got truesocial.com now you can
anybody can sign up from any device
including you can sign up on android but
you just have to kind of bookmark it and
go back
um and then we're hopeful to get into
the google play store here soon so then
it's simple for people that like to like
to have apps um and then it's really
about the features that we're that we're
going to be rolling out so so the
features
people love features there'll be more
features for sure but how worried about
are you about just some of the way the
internet works now so for example
truth is in the app store uh you know
twitter booted trump and then you know
there was this this concern that if elon
if he ends up getting twitter and he uh
puts trump back on if trump was to go
back on even though trump has said he
won't go back on it he's all in on truth
that the app store could then boot
twitter that there's that this is
multi-layered at many different levels
yeah so the only it's you cut right to
it right the only to plan the reason
that we
that we you know we went to apple first
um you know i've had a long
you know my whole career i dealt with
apple
um they're
they're
less woke than than others
they do have republicans that work there
i've dealt with them for a long time
president trump felt like we could work
with him and that's why we chose chose
apple first because we had to
you know
if you're not on the apple app store and
you're on the google play store it's
just tough to ultimately compete against
instagram and tick tock right so now the
good thing is is that
is that we're trying to be a family
friendly
place to be right so we're not
we're not looking to have any illegal
activity we're not you know we don't
want like porn on there and and and you
know some vulgarity is okay but you
can't get crazy about it so so we really
want to be family friendly and that
right now is you know so far
um we've had a great working
relationship with apple
um google we waited
uh you know kind of for that to be last
i mean we're because now we're up on the
web you know truesocial.com anybody can
get on to it even if apple was to was to
get rid of us you could still have your
account
um and google google's just more
problematic we already talked about some
of those issues but we're working with
them
um you know i i
i can't as a at this time i can't say
anything that they're trying to keep us
off the google play store
but look once again and we have a little
bit of an advantage that you know we're
not looking for violence and and illegal
activity on the platform we really want
to we really want to keep that to
you know a minimum
um i think that's going to make it
really tough for them to kick us off
their stores plus they already know look
they're not stupid here dave
republicans are likely going to smash
the left in the elections
you see big tech running ads constantly
all over the place saying how great they
are so i think they are a little bit
worried about what republicans could
could ultimately do
so look if we're i think here at true
social we're a family friendly place
where you know we're just not going to
censor people for politics you can talk
about any damn thing you want on the
platform you know politically
um but we don't want a lot of the
garbage that i think they would try to
use to wedge to to get us kicked off
these platforms and that's you know to
to our advantage
so when uh when elon you know now it's
about two months ago first started
grumbling about maybe buying twitter how
were you feeling about it and how did
you feel when president trump well i
don't remember which order it was did
president trump first say he wasn't
going to do it and then sort of went
after elon a little bit or was it the
other way around and and what do you
make of him just getting in the mix yeah
i don't make much of of the i think you
know i mean i i i've only met elon musk
a couple times but he seems like he's
obviously brilliant guy very very sharp
but kind of really very funny guy right
it's why he that's why he has you know a
big following on social media because
he's he's he's a creative dude
um but if you if you remember the fake
news has basically ignored this surprise
surprise
but the mission of of of our company you
know true social is very simple like
we're here to open the internet back up
and give people their voices back
right it's a very simple
very simple business plan and mission
and so you know i like to say that that
president trump didn't need a new
business
and i sure as hell didn't need a new job
uh it's just that what the hell do you
expect us to do when you kick all these
people off of social media i mean
including the former president united
states who had no voice at all plus
millions of his followers had no voice
at all not to mention all the censoring
that we that we already discussed if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell